the 2021 final season started with so
much hopes and dreams
now the field has been triangle down day
four the final four
2020 champion and bryce anders is the
number one seed led by john foyer time
war they will have their hands full
tonight with edward jones after a
sluggish start the 2021 spring champion
is regaining their momentum winning the
final online event of the season as well
as destroying the competition and the
hybrid of it well many see this as a two
horse race can wwt or ascension pull
some absence and make a go of it only
one corporation can get their name
agreed on the championship board who
will it be
let's get kraken
[Music]
it's time for the corporate chess league
finals as always my name is caleb denby
and i will be walking you through the
action here today uh and here in st
louis it's actually almost time for the
spring season of the corporate chess
league but this is unfinished business
we have to find out who
won the fall season uh you saw mike
there with the nutcracker this happened
some time ago but for the first time
today we will be taking you through the
action i haven't seen these games yet
you haven't seen these games yet who
knows who knows who won the fall uh the
fall season and got their name on the
chessboard uh in the finals of course we
had four different teams competing uh
that is down from the eighth in the
regular season these four qualified for
the playoffs so already a big win for
ascension worldwide technology
enterprise and edward jones of course of
those two teams enterprise and edward
jones have been battling back and forth
for that top spot on the corporate chess
league rankings
um how are the finals going to work here
tonight how are they going to work how
are they going to work let's find out we
have a four team round robin
and in each round robin there will be
one game per player per round that's
down from the two games for the virtual
uh sections of the events
we have four players per team with an
alternate allowed the game is in 10
minutes with no increment no delay
that's gonna make for some crazy time
scrambles especially over the board the
championship is determined by your total
match points not your game points so
unlike the regular season it doesn't
really matter if you win by a lot or win
by a little it's just about winning and
if we do end up in a tie we will have an
armageddon blitz match with five minutes
versus four minutes to uh go ahead and
break that time and with that what are
the teams playing for oh
well we might hear from alex here with a
little bit more about that
up there in the tournament hall we did
have everybody back here in person
competing in these finals you see there
um
some familiar faces you've got alex
there on the right the league
commissioner as well as jacob wilkins
who i believe was a special last minute
coach for the enterprise team we'll see
if he was able to help
and here are the prizes we have the
winning team for the season declared the
saint louis corporate chess league
champions they will get their named on
the coveted st louis corporate chess
league wooden board it's a beautiful
board and i would want to have my name
on it if possible
they also get to keep the board until
the next season the winning team also
gets some extra training with the
resident grand master at the st louis
chess club
uh so a lot on the line here the
bragging rights mean a lot to these
people believe me i've met them they
really really care about these bragging
rights uh but with that let's take it to
alex up in the tournament hall who i
believe has some opening words
i'll just kick us off with a few things
so i just want to say a thank you to all
the teams that competed this year
congrats to worldwide to enterprise
ascension edward jones but i mean
without everybody who's participating
and captains who are are keeping track
of your teams and getting people to come
and participate we wouldn't have a leak
so
thank you everyone for being here for
having your teams continue to support
this effort i want to say a big thank
you to ryan to mike uh caleb everybody
that's been at the st louis chess club i
think we owe them a big round of
applause
so i mean obviously like last year was
crazy with doing the transition to
online now being able to even come to a
place where back in person um all kudos
to the st louis
um chess club to be able to help
coordinate that and then i'll just
lastly mention we would love your
feedback i would personally love your
feedback i'll leave some cards just here
on the table
some of you guys have sent me things
that we've implemented in terms of uh
time control
do you like the two seasons so we just
last year we started doing a fall season
a spring season is it too much chess not
enough chess
give us some feedback on what you think
went well what you think might need to
be changed going into next year and uh
look forward to competing more next
season and it's great
mike that's it for me take it over thank
you i'll leave some cards up here
congratulations to the four teams that
have made it tonight so yeah the winner
all right so we do actually have those
first two round results already edward
jones and enterprise as expected the
first two or the top two seeds did
destroy the competition and end up
matched against each other in the finals
so that's who we're gonna be keeping an
eye on tonight we're jumping right into
the finals skipping all the fluff right
to the meat of the action here and so on
these two teams we've got four different
players as we said and i believe we are
going to start with the game between
john boyer for enterprise who is up
against the strong the mighty vishal
bardwash for edward jones so we're going
to be following these games in real time
and we'll see who is able to come out
ahead in these finals you see john there
on the left playing for enterprise and
vishal on the right uh they've shaken
hands and the game is underway we've got
e4 e6 d4 d5 all right it's a french c5
c3 knight c6 knight f3
wow lightning pace here bishop d3 um and
this is a gambit this is yeah john boyer
has officially sacrificed his d-pawn
and after knight bd2 uh he gives up the
pawn on c3 as well looks like he's going
to be playing for active development get
97 rook e1
and knight out to g6 okay what is jon
intending here uh let's see what what
opening prep he has in mind so he's
given up this pawn on d4 in classic
french style he doesn't care this is
some uh milner berry type stuff and oh
and he looks like he continues out with
c4 this makes a lot of sense you give up
that pawn you have to play very very
actively he's gonna look to rip open the
center get at that black king while it
is still stuck in the center
as always in chess whenever you capture
pawns the price that you pay is time
vishal comes with this move bishop c5
though trying to develop with tempo this
is exactly what you need to do here you
need to activate with tempo get your
pieces into play as quickly as you can
now i have to say i don't know that i
love
john's opening choice here it looks like
black is finishing development just a
single move away from castling and if
jon can't prove anything here early in
the opening he's going to be in some
trouble he's going to be in some very
very serious trouble
i don't see the way to prevent black
from castling if you play something like
rook to e2 black could even consider
moves like knight takes on um
e5 which would in fact be a sacrifice
but it might be a worthwhile one with
the f2 pawn getting ripped open and
let's see what move we have here rook b1
okay hitting the the black queen but
what is actually stopping me from
capturing this pawn
let's see so let's calculate a little
bit uh bishop f2 we would have king h1
and then
i suppose i have to go actually no king
f1 would be more accurate you have to
stay in touch with the bishop
then queen c5 i guess something like
knight b3 is john's intention
it seems very very shaky i don't know if
black can get away with capturing this
f2 pawn maybe it's a bit safer just to
calmly retreat back to c7 and say you
know what's what's the big deal i'm
gonna castle next turn i have an extra
pawn i don't need to take these crazy
risks with bishop f2
but whatever vishal does here he should
do it a little bit more quickly i think
he's
spending some time and as stated it's 10
plus 0 there's no increment there's no
delay if you're up a queen and you have
5 seconds on the clock you're not going
to win that game
so time always going to be a relevant
factor in the corporate chess league
makes these games rather exciting
so while we are following this one the
other three games in the round are
happening in tandem uh we've got tom
sack on board two up against justin
beckstead for edward jones tim neesham
for enterprise is against steven evans
on board three and darren dowler for
enterprise is up against the one the
only league commissioner alex curford on
board four and we do have a move it is
queen c7 i like this choice by vishal
don't get wrapped up in these tactics
which honestly i think are working out
for white somewhat surprisingly
instead just queen c7
add yet another attacker to this pawn on
e5 and keep your position safe keep your
position solid get ready to castle now
jon has to deal with some threats to the
e5 pawn he's likely considering taking
on d5
but maybe the problem here is that if
you take on d5 black will take your e
pawn not your d pawn i think white might
be happy with e takes d and some e6
sacrifices but you might just never get
that opportunity you might just see
knight takes on d5 takes on e5 after c
takes d when uh black is getting some
pieces off the board and again is just a
single step away from castling it's
hanging by a thread here for john boyer
he needs to pose some very serious
problems very very quickly and uh c
takes d has to be the move i cannot
imagine any other move here and so if
you only have one move
in general you you should play it
especially in 10 minute ooh and
knight to b3 okay i'm not in love with
this move now it is on the surface uh a
gain of a tempo but i suspect even d
take c4 would help solidify black's
position
you know if
white isn't able to get this e6
breakthrough he's going to find himself
kind of stopped up in the center instead
though the shawl keeps it calm just
retreats the bishop also not a bad idea
but i really would have liked to see him
consider this move d take c4 something
like um
knight c5 dc or cd3 and pieces are
coming off the board once again and
castles is on deck
and said though bishop e7 and whoops
spoilers queen e2 i think is about to be
played that's my prediction at least
we'll see
um john for the moment though still
mulling it over we'll back up one
and again i think c takes d should be
played but my my heart of hearts is
telling me that queen e2 might be john
boyer's choice
he thinks it over
uh i guess he is probably worried about
this business here happening on e5
so that would be the reasoning to play
this move queen e2 if you really think
knight e5 is going to be a strong
response to c takes d
then you can play queen e2 to try and
prevent this
but again e2 just starts to feel like
it's missing the flow right white is
sacrificed upon in the opening we have
to keep the flow going keep the pieces
coming um keep the keep the threats
coming otherwise black will be able to
consolidate and actually claim some
advantage with an extra pawn
so c takes d queen e2 what else could
you consider here you're never really
taking this knight on g6 this bishop is
often white's best piece in openings
like this where you have a dark squared
pawn in the center and so even though
bishop takes g6 would seemingly remove
this knight
with tempo from the threat of the e5
pawn giving you time to take on d5 i
don't think this would be
quite the correct way to go and look at
that it is queenie too how do i do it
how do i do it all right michelle's turn
now let's see what he can come up with
here i would be tempted to do two
different things number one castles
always tempted to castle uh number two d
take c4 might be a useful move to insert
once again
and the reasoning is the exact same as
before and he does play dc4 we get
bishop c4
once again the reasoning is that you
really don't want to deal with this e6
break it looks like a you know like this
pawn would just be hanging on e6 but of
course once this pawn is captured then
the major pieces you start to feel their
power in the position
and it looks like we do have d take c
bishop takes c and castles king side by
the shawl so far so sensible
and it's not as if black's position is
perfect just yet he does still have some
awkwardness with these pieces this
bishop on d7 in particular not very well
placed but i expect rooks to the center
even a move like bishop e8 just keeping
things very compact very solid and the
extra pawn is eventually going to be
very telling
um coming as a keracon player uh i am
used to seeing this position with this
bishop on f5 when black would just be
winning but you know vishal chose the
french so we can't blame him too much
it's bishop d2
by uh john boyer this move is a little
bit a little bit of a head scratcher
there i'm not sure what's going on with
bishop to d2 i understand the sentiment
you want to develop your pieces but what
is this bishop doing on d2 that it
wasn't already doing on c1 i'm not so
sure
quick move by vishal it's b6
okay b6 um
this is sort of uh
this this tends to happen in a lot of
chess games where one player plays a
move and maybe i don't get it maybe it
doesn't make much sense to me but the
other player sort of
believes the point the point being maybe
one day white wants to put this bishop
on a5 skewering some major pieces so
vishal seems to be responding in kind
here with this move b6 just sort of uh
believing not necessarily believing the
threat but believing in the move in the
idea and we do have a couple more moves
it looks like rook c1 rook c8 and now
john comes out with bishop a6 and yeah
this is why i didn't love this move b6
it's more weakening than it is
strengthening these light squares are
going to be very very important uh quick
move by vishal rook over to b8 now but i
think john is slowly but surely starting
to take over once again he's got control
down the c file now uh thanks to this
big weakening move b6 by vishal much
better just bring the rooks to the
center develop your pieces stay compact
i liked his strategy early in the
opening b6 the first real mistake i can
point to and say
now you might have some problems
and with that john is going to slow down
here which is not a bad idea even in
rapid chess when you know your opponent
is starting to you know stray from the
path that is a good time to uh to spend
some of your precious seconds on the
clock you want to be sure wait a second
i i think i have something good here i
don't want to mess it up now and it
looks like we have the move uh bishop b5
queen b7 by vishal and now rook c2 by by
john boyer here so
i don't really love bishop e5 to be
honest i think better instead is rook c2
first you just want to activate along
this file bishop was great on a6
preventing these rooks from coming to
defend and now we have rook c2 it's the
shaw's turn i believe
and he plays bishop or sorry is that
knight b4 yeah knight b4 as john leaves
the board
who's the commentator my name is caleb
david nice to see you i'm caleb i teach
lectures here every tuesday night if
you're interested
um but in knight b4 by by vishal and
yeah you get the feeling that something
has slipped here for
john boyer once again bishop on a6 did a
great job not only controlling the c8
square but preventing this queen from
stepping out of of these pins after
bishop e5 and rook c2 knight to b4 and
even though vishal did make some
weaknesses here it looks like he's got
all his squares under control once again
these light square bishops are going to
be coming off the board
but first it looks like capture and a
capture
and rook
e to c1
and now these light square bishops are
likely going to be coming off the board
that was black's worst piece in the
position and with that piece
disappearing now uh the the threats are
running out threats are running out for
john he's going to try to invade on
these uh dark squares which is why we
might see vishal do something like
rook c8 i would expect and both players
are gone from the board where have they
gone it's a 10 minute game you can't
just be walking away like this
what is going on here
and yeah hello to everyone joining us in
the chat thank you so much for being
here i'm excited we're going over the
finals of the corporate chess league and
right now it's all up to vishal both
players back at the board we do see a
rook to see it not the one that i
recommended but the other one which is
fair enough in general i like bringing
the b rook here just because the the d
file is also open that might be a good
home for the other rook likely it's not
going to make a difference and what is
going on all right we have takes and
takes
and yeah
so far so good for vishal he has
navigated the treacherous waters that he
found himself in he is combating white
on the sea file not going to allow any
invasions uh and he's traded off his
worst piece and this b-pawn is simply
extra
it looks like g3 now by john boyer a
good solidifying move but being solid
when you're down a pawn probably not
going to be enough
how much time do they have left that is
an excellent question i can't quite see
myself
uh but i would imagine the the minutes
are disappearing quickly once again they
started with only game intent and yeah
john down to just two minutes and 45
seconds vishal with five minutes left
and it looks like a5 is his choice
yeah more more slightly weakening moves
by vishal but he is in fact cementing
that bishop on b4 so while this move
gives up some more of these light
squares
vishal is staying
solid in a sense by making sure his
pieces aren't so loose loose pieces drop
off that's the thing especially in rapid
chess so i don't hate this move at all i
would have actually even preferred
something like bishop way back to f8
bishops are long range pieces they
sometimes do their best work from afar
where they cannot be hassled by rooks
pawns or knights and i think the bishop
on f8 would be a a nice piece
for that purpose instead a5 knight
b to d2 by by john okay so we have these
rooks in tension here on the c file now
that we see this move i would expect
yeah rook takes c2 i think black was
holding off on this move because queen
takes c2 would take control the file
this knight interrupts that connection
with the queen so now we do see a trade
and the other rook can come back to
contest if the queen had captured rook
c8 not gonna be possible
it looks like we have takes and takes
now on the board and it once again is up
to john and it looks like things are are
getting pretty grim here this bishop is
going to be a far better piece than
either of white's knights in this end
game see this e5 pawn is now a weakness
and it's black with control over the
open file and the opportunities to
invade we get knight e4 by john
and why not give a check
why not come in why not come in and
invade start making some threats around
the the black king instead we see h6 by
vishal okay this move as well you can
start with but uh why not start with a
check and then play h6 but
i'm not going to get mad at anybody for
uh
for
making left for their king i i respect
it h4 by john and we should see the
moves start to uh to come in at a much
faster pace here as we just saw john was
down to i think under two minutes now
michelle gives a check king g2 and queen
a1 it looks like
and yeah you don't need to do anything
special here as vishal you just need to
keep some pressure up against e5 that's
gonna prevent jon from getting a little
too active
and in the meantime slowly but surely
start to push your pawns we see queen c2
by john and i'm not a mathematician but
that's one attacker two attackers and
only one defender are you guys seeing
what i'm seeing am i am i missing
something i think this is a free pawn
for vishal and he takes it that pawns
for him if it's free it's for me says
vishal
uh knight takes e5 so john relying on
this check to give him some active
counter play but thanks to this h6 move
of course just king age seven and what's
what's the big idea i'm not so sure
uh john's time really dwindling now it
looks like he's around a minute and 10
seconds uh if i can trust my vision test
wow i am good all right queen c8 on the
board okay and oh what's this
this looks like a result on board two uh
i'm being told that justin beckstead has
won on board two for edward jones that
is a massive result we see bishop f8 by
vishal so vishal of course with the lead
in this game playing for edward jones uh
if he is able to secure the victory here
edward jones would be off to a 2-0 lead
in the finals you only need two and a
half points to win
so this could be massive for the finals
here we could see a blowout
queen e8 by john boyer is the choice
uh so this move is sort of cagey
just uh keeping an eye on f7
excuse me keeping nine f7 here
and let's see what's this he's touching
the queen queen oh sorry we get a trait
of knights first now queen a2
and is that a resignation
that's a resignation by john boyer that
is it john has resigned vishal secures
the victory and i believe now we go
quickly to tim nisham against stephen
evans so actually that is steven with
the white pieces there playing for
edward jones on board three tim neesham
with the black pieces needs a victory
here to keep enterprises uh finals hopes
alive uh absolutely needs a victory that
is the only way for enterprises to stay
in a draw on either board 3 or board 4
for edward jones is going to
secure the victory and let's see if we
can catch up the players here it looks
like rook c1 king e2 and now nida for
check what is this the rook falls the
rook falls and this is uh probably going
to keep edward jones hopes alive
i think we are about to see rook a1
there it is
and now it's up to uh
up to steven to try to do the impossible
here goes knight c2 uh and it may not
look that bad at first glance and you
might think it's just an exchange but
uh in this case the exchange is going to
be more than enough in most instances
the the outside past pawns here are not
going to be uh very effective the rook
just sort of dominates the knight in
these end games and black will be able
to bring the king in
start pushing the pawns and we'll have
an easy victory that is if he can keep
his time advantage all right we get rook
to g1
g3 defending the pawn
rook to h1 now i like this just inducing
the pawns to move forward rook c1
hitting the knight just quick moves king
d2 rook b1 okay
yeah i mean above all else you can't
really go wrong here with black so just
playing quick moves that
pass the move back to your opponent not
a bad idea just wait for them to hang
something in a rapid game this is not a
bad way to play
okay it looks like knight c2 and now g5
okay we get takes and h takes would have
liked to see f takes there with a past
pawn oh and that is a flag i believe
believe white is out of time we don't
even need to see the technique and with
that enterprise does keep their hopes
alive but what's this we're on the last
board we're on the final board what's
going on let's catch up we've got the
pawn on each three alex says the white
pieces here he has rook versus two pawns
but those pawns are very far advanced
okay those pawns are on the sixth rank
what is what is happening okay rook g1
is this gonna be enough to hold the game
um h2 no g2
why not h2 i think h2 is winning
oh wow black has blown it h2 won the
game
now after h2 white is able to capture on
g2 he would not have been able to do
this if the king were not on f3
and now we see the queen and this end
game i believe is just going to be a
draw
okay but alex has six seconds on the
clock
six seconds to six seconds
who can go faster
that's a repetition that's a repetition
game ends in a draw and with that alex
kurford has secured the victory for
edward jones what a finish there at the
end it started off 2-0 for edward jones
and i thought we had a blowout but then
uh tim neesham getting it done on board
three and darren dowler very very nearly
getting alex kirford once again if i can
show this on the board here i think
after rook to uh g1 this move h2 would
just be strictly winning the game if you
move the rook along the second rank to
h1 for example i go king h3 g2 on deck
not much you can do about that and if
you move somewhere over here again g2
and wait a second is there like some
okay this might be this might be some
high-level stuff here might be some
high-level stuff but i believe i am
actually winning this game uh because i
can queen and if you try to chase my
king
i chase you up here no more rook h8
that's the end of your game but wait
check
hold on but maybe then i come this way
maybe this is like some really really
crazy draw but uh h2 i would be very
surprised if if the players were able to
find this much more likely i think we
would have seen this when after queen's
black is of course winning
but maybe this is some impossible
resource where uh
white is able to to keep the balance
here by virtue of these check meeting
threats on the back row i'm gonna cheat
and ask the engine here for a second and
that's yeah this is some some miracle
draw so study your end games everybody
but h2 definitely would have been the
best try in the game instead we saw g2
which of course allowed this move king
f3 which he much with a much simpler
draw after king takes on uh g2
um
so with that draw alex curford secures
the victory big congratulations to
edward jones uh the the entire team what
a performance here in the finals that
was super exciting um okay with that i
think we are going to hear from some of
the players up in the tournament hall uh
regarding the the crazy crazy match that
just finished
how confident were you that your company
had it
uh had it won after you got the victory
over john had to feel good yeah i know
honestly the guys are great i've played
with them practice with them love them
uh very much and uh and yeah i was
pretty confident that i knew at least
one other person would get a result for
sure and then i knew it was going to be
a 50 50 because i know enterprise
players how good they are
so uh i just figured
i got the win thankfully and i just hope
a couple others are able to get results
and we can we can avoid the sudden death
and uh and thankfully it happened and
i'm very happy who's the mvp of your
team this year if such a thing existed
i'd say honestly alex and justin not me
um i've had other commitments throughout
the season so i didn't get to play as
much as i wanted to um so those guys
kind of really can put down all the all
the guys honestly
i think those two for sure because
they've had to play the hardest boards
and play all the guys i usually play um
and they've done fantastic they've done
really well so i would definitely hand
it to them
and i'm just happy that i got to
participate in the last
three rounds
so very happy about that so close to the
championship right but you came up short
what are your feelings right after this
game i mean it hurts um but you know
what michelle's a great player ever
joins good people so i mean they're all
great players so you know the fact that
we competed with them is fantastic
there's always next year so we're gonna
keep playing keep prepping
and you know what we'll maybe make the
finals again and win next year during
the game both of you got up from the
board like there was some dispute and
then just sat back down what happened no
dispute we were debating on a draw that
at that time it was it was a drawing
position
and so we wanted to look at each other's
opponents to make sure like hey if it
was a level match then we were caught in
the draw but
since it wasn't that we just played on
what would you say went wrong for you
uh
well
towards the end game i misplayed to prep
i prepped to like move 20.
and on move 18 i deviated on accident
and said whoops
so i mean you know
and that it is what it is
so you know like i said i won't take
anything away from you sean he's a
fantastic player i'm happy that he won i
have no you know
so i just there's always that [ __ ] man
dude i didn't want to say anything
because you were down on time i was like
i was trying to be like probably you got
to draw this game you should have drove
this game or win this game like you know
unless i really didn't have any ideas so
man i was like because i swear he had
he definitely had a queen in there yeah
yeah i saw that too you had the walk off
game it wasn't a victory a draw the only
draw of the tournament did you know the
situation you were in at the time of the
draw going into the last match i i knew
we had to get at least two and a half
to win the corporate chess league i had
no idea where i was i hadn't looked up
had any of my teammates to even see
reactions from their games and so in
that last
two and a half minutes i had no idea
where i was where our team was right so
uh were you did you have any worries
during your game like did you have what
was going through your head during the
game because i mean it was the last game
there's something romantic about it i
mean at the beginning i had darren
i he had plundered a bishop i think i
had that little adrenaline rush when you
know that you're like up and now you
have to play
winning and it was one of those things
where then
i immediately
dropped a brook good to see you tim
thanks darren
and then i immediately drop a forked
position and then i'm on my heels again
and so then the rest of the game was
just a grind how relieved are you that
there's not gonna be an armageddon i am
so happy uh we are familiar with
armageddon in fact we have gone to
armageddon against enterprise two times
and we are 50 50 i believe for the whole
championship and so very happy to avoid
armageddon and capture the win all right
what's your future outlook for edward
jones in the corporate chess league hey
i think that we're gonna stay
competitive uh i think that
other teams though are certainly
increasing some teams have coaches now
so i'm gonna have to talk with our our
higher-ups and see if we can uh you know
spend a little money get some coaching
too but uh excited about next year i
think we're going to continue to expand
as a as a team and as a leader thank you
alex yep all right
all right big smile on alex crawford's
face that night uh what a game to end
everything off once again h2 and white
would have had to find a miracle draw
after g2 in the game uh alex's task was
was not quite as difficult and he got
the job done with only six seconds on
the clock absolutely insane finale now
if you guys enjoyed the action here
today you will definitely want to join
us in i believe 13 days is when the
spring season will be starting and if
after tonight you've seen these games
you think you can take these players on
and you are a corporation in the st
louis area please please please reach
out to us we would love for you to get
involved with the corporate chess league
it's a lot of fun i have a lot of fun
with it the players really really enjoy
it and i think you all will too
all right with that big big big
congratulations to alex and the edward
jones team uh congratulations to
enterprise as well on a very hard-fought
match a very well played season they
were the regular season champs and then
uh edward jones reasserting their
dominance in the playoffs fun stuff all
right as always my name is caleb denby
thank you all so much for joining me
here for the corporate chess league
finals we will see you all uh on
february
let me check the date 24th february 24th
for the spring season
you